all right so we've talked about git and
github but how do you actually get
things done on github how do you go
about creating a project and introducing
change this is the github workflow there
are five basic steps that will walk you
through how to introduce change so let's
say you're working on a project that
project would be stored in a github
repository and all of the code that was
in production is on a branch called
master now that's important we don't
ever want to make changes directly onto
master so the first thing we do is
create another branch when you create a
branch it's creating what feels like an
exact replica of master so you have a
safe sandbox to make changes without
affecting anything that's in production
after you create your branch you make
some commits now commits are sort of
like making changes whenever you make a
set of changes you make a commit and it
stores all of those changes by taking a
snapshot of your repository your project
at that point in time so if this circle
is a commit you could make one tiny
change or you can make a few get lets
you choose once you've made some commits
to introduce your changes you'd open up
a pull request on github comm in this
pull request you're comparing the branch
you made with another branch like master
it gives you an opportunity to look at
the differences between those two
branches and show other people the
differences as well once you do that and
they see the changes then you can
collaborate on them they might give you
a thumbs up and say it looks great or
they might have some critiques and
suggestions and that's good that's the
point right
so you've opened the pull requests
you've gotten some feedback maybe even
made some more changes and made some
more commits on that branch once you've
reached a consensus that it's in a good
place you merge when you merge you're
taking the branch you created and the
commits on that branch and putting them
back into master so all of those
snapshots are in the production branch
so just remember the five basic steps
for the github workflow create a branch
make some commits open up a pull request
collaborate and merge your bridge
you